if I say Venice do you imagine yourself
gliding down the Grand Canal serenaded
by a gondolier there's no doubt that the
gondola is a symbol of Venice Italy but
how did this curious banana-shaped black
boat get its distinctive look the
origins of the Venetian gondola are lost
to history but by the 1500s some 10,000
gondolas transported dignitaries
merchants and goods through the city's
canals in fact Venice teamed with many
types of handmade boats from utilitarian
rafts to the doges own ostentatious
gilded barge like a modern-day taxi
system gondolas were leased to boat men
who made the rounds of the city's ferry
stations passengers paid a fare to be
carried from one side of the Grand Canal
to the other as well as to other points
around the city but gondoliers soon
developed a bad rap historical documents
describe numerous infractions involving
boat men including cursing gambling
extorting passengers even occasional
acts of violence to minimize the
unpredictability of canal travel
Venetian citizens who could afford it
purchased their own gondolas just as a
celebrity might use a private car and
driver today these wealthy Venetians
hired to private gondoliers to ferry
them around the city and maintain their
boats the gondola soon became a status
symbol much like an expensive car with
custom fittings carved and gilded
ornamentation and seasonal fabrics like
silk and velvet however the majority of
gondolas seen today are black because in
1562 Venetian authorities decreed that
all but ceremonial gondolas be painted
black in order to avoid sinfully
extravagant displays apparently venetian
authorities did not believe in pimping
their rides still some wealthy Venetians
chose to pay the funds in order to
maintain their ornamental gondolas a
small price to keep up appearances
the distinctive look of the gondola
developed over many centuries each
gondola was constructed in a family boat
yard called a squid Oh from their
fathers and grandfathers sons learned
how to select and seasoned pieces of
cherry elm fir larch lime mahogany oak
and walnut the gondola makers began with
a wooden template that may have been
hammered into the workshop floor
generations earlier from this basic form
they attached fore and aft Stern's
then formed the longitudinal planks and
ribs that made up the frame of a boat
designed to glide through shallow narrow
canals a gondola has no straight lines
or edges its familiar profile was
achieved through an impressive fire and
water process that involved warping the
boards with torches made of marsh Reed's
set ablaze however the majority of the
500 hours that went into building a
gondola involved the final stages
preparing surfaces and applying
successive coats of waterproof varnish
the varnish was a family recipe as
closely guarded as one for risotto or a
homemade sauce yet even with the
woodwork finished the gondola was still
not complete specialized artisans
supplied their gondola making colleagues
with elaborate covered passenger
compartments upholstery and ornaments of
steel and brass our makers became
integral partners to the gondola makers
the Venetian or lock or fork Allah began
as a simple wooden fork but evolved into
a high-precision tool that allowed a
gondolier to guide the ore into many
positions by the late 1800s gondola
makers began to make the left side of
the gondola wider than the right as a
counterbalance to the force created by a
single gondolier this modification
allowed rowers to steer from the right
side only and without lifting the oar
from the water while these modifications
improved gondola travel they were not
enough to keep pace with motorized boats
today only about 400 gondolas glide
through the waterways of Venice and each
year fewer authentic gondolas are turned
out by hand but along the alleys street
signs contain words in Venetian dialect
for the locations of old boat yards or
makers and ferry stations imprinting the
memory of the boat building trades that
once kept life in the most serene
Republic gliding along at
clip